plusted what I have to do this it's the
trump card
oh the Joker is not funny anymore do you
kick that over deliberately I think that
may have been a digression our noses
remember how at the beginning of Trump's
presidency we talked a lot about his
divisive misogynist racist conduct we
hardly ever bring it up these days we've
all acclimatized let's face it for
Donald Trump to shock us now the bar is
pretty high so congratulations mr.
president
by endorsing the message of an extreme
right-wing group you have successfully
reached a new low the obscure Britain
first which campaigns on an openly white
supremacist platform has been given a
global boost thanks to the leader of the
free world who are proving Lee retweeted
their overtly Islamophobic posts even to
resume usually reluctant to alienate our
supposed ally has issued a statement
condemning Trump's messages it's time
for her to go a step further any
suggestion of Trump being given a state
visit must now be unequivocally
withdrawn Mei said British people
overwhelmingly reject the prejudiced
rhetoric of the far-right which is the
antithesis of the values this country
represents it's time we rejected the
president who endorses them too
so I watched the videos that he had
sweeted and I actually found them
genuinely upsetting particularly the one
where there was the guy on the crutches
which I worked necessarily going to all
the details of but I found that really
it I just it upset it genuinely upset me
and the you when you share content like
that whoever you are you're doing it to
provoke a strong horrible reaction
against the perpetrators that's the only
reason you are trying to create division
and hatred there's no other reason for
that so I feel very strongly that he
shouldn't have shared those tweets
there's no real reason to have shared
those tweets other than to whip up a
frenzy in hatred so I think he was very
very wrong to have done so I don't think
he probably recognized the Briton first
thing so whilst it's prominence he was
particularly with Joe Cox etc I don't
think it has that prominence in America
so I don't think there was a natural
link there and an intention to endorse a
particular group I think that was a
accidental byproduct but I think he was
very wrong just to make plain the person
who murdered Joe course was not a member
of the organisation use those words just
so he gets it so that's the first point
the second point is I don't think he
should be denied a state visit I think
that people have been trying to stop
that state visit pretty much from day
one and they will just jump on anything
that they can find to stop that because
they just don't like him he is the
President of the United States we need
particularly post brexit a relationship
with the United States so I don't think
we should be stopping that state visit
either either you do have net income
well you don't let in don't think you
should let breaks it either what he's
done it goes beyond the pale or is it
it's my my response to a state visit
isn't to do with brexit I've always said
he should be entitled to gone beyond the
pale I'm gonna conflict' confessor me
this is the first time I feel completely
conflicted and I actually don't know and
it's the first time in living memory and
I actually felt myself doing this on the
radio it's totally wrong it's absolutely
inexcusable
it's unpardonable
but but and on my first reaction is we
are not like this in Britain we are a
torrent nation but let's just remember
we have incredible affinity they are our
quote but among our closest allies and
although it is Trump we we are also
talking about the bond between the
British people and the American people
who have been through Wars together my
late father served in the war and that
generation did so to allow this
loathsome individual and by the way I've
never been in tradition Trump because 63
four million Americans I've always tried
to see the better side of that's over
from now on in that's it you've gone too
far your loathsome individual but does
that mean you break relations between UK
and US I honestly
Mashal admit the park post brags Britain
is very important is that he's one of
the guys who said we'd be first in line
to get a deal but you know since time
immemorial we have had relationships
with the American presence and you know
I think our mistake is I mean I think
he's an idiot as well I think our
mistake is we keep expecting him to
morph into the kind of president that we
know and understand he's never gonna be
there he won't he won't care about any
of this Kristin he really doesn't care
all he cares about is representing the
people who voted for the people in
Middle America so none of this touches
him and was frothing at the mouth and
saying you shouldn't come you shouldn't
come you know I heard someone the radio
today say you know you should be allowed
to come and watch the demonstrations no
because that's just gonna that I never
said a swear word that's gonna hack them
off that's gonna really mess him up and
he's gonna is likely to take spite out
on this country we don't want to do that
Frank
but we can't alienate him either we even
though however you like it or not well I
think the tragic thing is is that
clearly from the evidence of the Trump's
president Trump's tweet this morning
which directly accused Teresa may have
so trying to undermine him he just
doesn't care and I think what we're
seeing is a real degradation in in
actually art of international diplomacy
just don't come back she's just in case
you don't see so the views to resume
this is from President Trump don't focus
on me focus on the destructive radical
Islamic terrorism that is taking place
within the United Kingdom we are doing
just fine and I know there pains me to
say this I know that Carol will well her
eyes probably right me but I just feel
that since first brexit and then Trump
we have
seen a sort of cautioning of discourse
which he is spearheading and encouraging
because it encourages his own power base
so let's see how we reacted to visit or
not to visit you've danced around a bit
I think he's got to come he's still
present in the Adsense but let's see
what should a muna who who speaks about
many things and he's now responded to
the Trump tweets I don't think the
President of the United States a
president who has not only promoted
bigotry misogyny and racism in his own
country I don't think he has welcomed
here
I think the invite that has been made to
him to come to our country in early 2018
it should be withdrawn I don't agree I
think that when he goes low we go high
and we show president Trump how grown up
country with courtesy at its heart of
its institutions operates who said this
at the start you said this has given
this this group this Britain fist is
only about a thousand we have now made
them so for those of you well I guess
all of you who think that the physician
be canceled is there or you want to be
one a line that because I mean Carol you
said you know there are a line we need
to keep that relationship is there a
line or is there nothing that he could
do that would make you think that we
need to stand up I think he's a
dangerous buffoon I do but and put foot
for four years at least he's
representing the biggest superpower on
the planet we can't just say off you go
we don't like what you say and that's it
the tragedy that all of this is you
don't usually come to what we stand for
in this piece you see is but yeah he is
and the show you know when he says he
have don't focus on me focus on the
radical Islamic terrorism you know no
one's doing that we're just focusing on
his stupidity in his idiocy and doing
this and that's the tragic day don't
forget that we're it's the government
that he would be engaging with and that
government is not just three today there
are ministers and and I just want to
read you a Sergey Javed said because for
people who are actually personally
affected by the kind of rhetoric the
Trump is endorsing
of whom Sergey Java does when he said so
POTUS has endorsed the views of a vile
hate-filled racist organization that
hates me and people like me he is wrong
and I refuse to let it go and say
nothing you know these are the issues
people in government are personally
infected by the kind of message that he
thinks that it's a mistake to make it
America all about Donald Trump and he
comes over as president of the biggest
pop you know core superpower which we
have to do business with and you know he
would love the changes right Rachel all
honesty you have a principle by which
you live all you think well actually is
not quite sentence because China or
Britain or a US are quite powerful he
should not be invited to the state with
it
Nick come on I know it was her line when
he goes low we go high that's what for
me sorry I'm alone that's strong so the
rest of you but a much more think you
should be allergic I'm a Theresa May she
probably really wants to tell him to do
one and she can't she has to deal with
this guy and and and she has to and she
has to tread a very fine line I sorry